finding help during the holidays today
Goodwill is holding its annual holiday
resource fair non-profits and government
agencies will be providing services and
they'll even be a food distribution
pop-up the fair takes place today at
Boulevard Mall so central location to
the valley and that's where our Candace
Charles is this morning she's live with
a look at what all is being offered our
our Santa Charles this morning all right
good morning Candace tell us more
Sherry honestly I like that name better
good morning to you guys good morning
folks when you have to choose between
presents food and paying the rent the
holidays really can be difficult but
Candace Claus or St Charles had some
help from the folks at Goodwill let's
look at the few things they have here
this is just some of the food that
they'll be sharing with the community
today and I'm joined by Goodwills Morgan
Waldron thank you so much for joining us
tell us about the services people can
get your and about the food that will be
distributed yes today starting at 11 A.M
you can come register for the food
pantry as well as Supportive Services so
Career Services housing assistance child
care assistance Transportation
assistance if you're in need there's
pretty much something here for you no
matter what your needs are we can find a
way to help you now this is the sixth
time you guys are doing the holiday
resource fair and you mentioned that
more than 100 people show up what have
you been seeing in the last few years
what are some of the families saying
when they come here definitely the
family is really really appreciate the
help with the food because it's it's
heartbreaking if you can't feed your
children and that's why we love to throw
this event around the holidays to give
you that extra hand up for the holidays
and make it that much easier so you can
really have that holiday Joy with your
family and it's really simple right
people can just come down here with
their ID right yes bring a valid ID
check in at 11 and you'll be registered
for the food pantry and the food
distribution will begin at 12 but don't
wait come early because it will go fast
uh so Morgan thank you for the work you
guys do in the community you heard
yourself come early it starts at 11 and
come right here to The Atrium the
entrance right here off of I think
that's uh Maryland Parkway here at
Boulevard Mall Of course bring your ID
and it runs until 2 pm food will be
distributed as we mentioned at noon we
got to cover all details on our website
eightnewsnow.com for now live from the
Boulevard Mall I'm Candace Charles 8
News Now